Downloading code into the kernel and secure binding, how is this secure? This is
a bit dicey. Here, the library operating system is given an ability to
drop code into the kernel. The rationale
is purely a performance one. Namely, avoid
border crossings. But obviously it can be
a serious security loophole. Even in spin
we've noticed that a core service may have to step outside the language
enforce protection mechanism. In order to control
hardware resources. Bottom line is, while both
SPIN and Exokernel start out with the idea of allowing extensibility, they may
have to necessarily restrict who will be allowed to do such extensions. Not any
arbitrary user. It has to be a trusted set of users.